this is exactly the kind of question
which yesterday's brief look at credit
cards everybody introduce that idea will
equip you to do so just have a look at
it with me and let's read together but I
have a pen in your hand while you're
reading 2011 HSC it's multiple choice
for this one a television was purchased
for $2,100 okay I'm gonna start doing
some highlighting as I go through heat
$2,100 they tell you the time that it
was the date rather that it was
purchased the 12th of April using a
credit card simple interest that's
something worth highlighting was charged
at a rate of they give you the interest
rate and I'm not just going to highlight
the number I'm also going to highlight
the time period that comes with it
because sometimes you'll be given
monthly interest sometimes you'll be
given daily interest and as you can
imagine that has a big impact on how you
do the question there were no other
purchases on this credit card account
there was no interest free period now
just before we keep on reading what that
means is what I mentioned before do
remember what that special number of
days wasn't that I told you yesterday
55 okay now that's an industry standard
but depending on the kind of credit card
you got maybe you don't have enough
money or you don't have a mortgage which
is a big source of credit cards if you
don't have that kind of thing then maybe
the credit card you're going to get
doesn't have an interest free period
period that means the 12th of April as
soon as you've made this purchase they
start charging you interest okay we keep
going the period for which interest was
charged included the date of purchase
and the date of payments so in other
words the Toth of April that's one of
the days they're gonna charge interest
they don't start charging us the next
day okay
now the actual question what amount was
paid what amount was paid when the
account was paid in full and then they
provide the date that it was paid okay
so you can see the first thing you can
see is I've chosen a horrendous color so
let's fix that you can see that there's
a whole bunch of information there that
we need to kind of weave together before
we start to actually write out
solution I want to point out that when
you have a look at all this information
in front of you you can start to tag
some other things based on the fact that
this is a simple interest question right
so what's the formula that comes into
your mind when you see I equals PRN okay
so if you jot that down there you can
start to look at this and say well
what's the principle what's the rate
what's the number of time periods okay
so have a look for example where is P
where's the principle it's the it's the
2,000 frequently it's the first number
that you see right so I'm just going to
label that P for myself okay
the interest rate that's another thing
that's easy to support where is it 19
point seven four so I'm just gonna Chuck
an hour in there now when you get to n
when you get to end that's a little bit
trickier they don't tell you the number
of years or months or days you kind of
have to infer it and calculate what
information will I use yep the April and
the May right like I need both of those
days together your number of days in
between that's going to be in okay can
we quickly work that out there's some
days in April and there's some days in
May there are January Martin or there
are 30 days okay in April now keep in
mind that 12 is included right the 12th
is included so the way that I think
about it is the days 1 to 11 they're out
right you don't have to worry about
those but all the other days they're
gonna charge interest yeah so if there's
30 in total but 11 of them you haven't
made the purchase how many days in April
do you get charged interest 19 in
addition to those 19 days in April there
are 20 days in May 19 plus 20 right so
the end that I'm after is going to be 39
I can see where I get it from does that
make sense okay now one more thing
before I actually put pen to paper to
put the solution down that will tell me
that'll tell me the interest right am I
being asked to calculate the interest
I need the full amount don't know now
obviously I'm going to need the interest
but the full amount here it is the full
amount is not just the interest it
includes the purchase itself the
principle right so the actual amount
that gets paid is going to be principal
plus the interest which is P iron does
that make sense yes okay right now just
because we can all see this together I'm
gonna try and squeeze this in here so I
know what all of these numbers are I've
put the effort in to identify all the
bits in the question so now I'm going to
substitute this is turn from a an FM
question into an AM question I'm just
substituting into algebra okay so let's
have a go at this principle 2100 plus
principal again now when I get to this R
and this n right you guys know you've
seen some of the questions sometimes you
have to convert the interest rate to a
different like per month per day
whatever and sometimes you don't do I
have to convert in this case okay so
because per annum I have a choice write
the number of days that I worked out I
can say that's 39 out of 365 days right
so I can change the N that's how much of
a time period yes alternatively I can
say oh thanks ash I can say how much
interest do I get we'll each day that
percentage right what was it 0.197 for
I've written it as a decimal okay each
day I don't get nineteen point seven
four percent thank goodness I only get
that divided by 365 right that's how
much it's a tiny little bit but it
happens every day right times 39 days do
you see I can I can convert the interest
rate or I can convert the number of time
periods you're dividing one number by
365 or another night you get the same
answer at the end okay
all right I've lined it all up the last
thing that's required is to press the
buttons on that thing okay so there's
someone beat me to it has someone got a
number
that isn't know I'll wait for you
I'm guessing it's gonna start with two
one for at least I really hope for okay
so it's always reassuring when you have
an answer and it lines up with one of
the options that's in multiple choice so
there's part there's arm option C
question okay yeah that's a great
question so the answer is I can if I
want to let's consider what I would do
if I were to write it like that I'm
gonna write PRN all over again right
he's P the principal here's the rate now
when I say M this is what I was alluding
to up here right when I say n I'm like
well this is how much of a year that 39
days is right how much were you well but
just have a look you see this line this
line here versus this line here do you
see they're the same thing um where
whether I on that color again whether I
divide here or divide here you can do
them in any order it's really the same
thing okay so you can go ahead and you
can crunch the numbers in your
calculator if you like to contain
yourself that you will get the same 2144
at the end